Sommer in der Stadt Öffnungen aufatmen
unbeschwerte Nähe wurde incidenzen
sinken ist das Lebensgefühl
himmelhochjauchzend und doch ein Riss
hat sich eingeschlichen er zieht sich
durch viele Beziehungen und Familien
verschwörungsideologie rund um Corona
und angeblich bitterböse Eliten Spalten
die Gesellschaft schüren Misstrauen Hass
und Unverständnis wie werden Menschen zu
verschwörungsgläubigen
niemand steht ja morgens auf und glaubt
an eine große corona-verschwörung
sondern man kann sich das so ein
bisschen vorstellen naja wie die Reise
von Alice im Wunderland in den
Kaninchenbau umso wichtiger ist glaube
ich zu reflektieren das Personen die an
Verschwörungen Glauben keine schlechten
Menschen sind und auch keine psychisch
gestörten Menschen sind da geht es um
Anerkennung Selbstwert Kontrolle da geht
es auch um Geborgenheit was wollen diese
Leute wie sehen die sich selbst wir
sehen die ihre zum Beispiel Corona
Skepsis
klimawandelskepsis impfskepsis aus ihrer
eigenen Perspektive darum geht's im
Gespräch bleiben verstehen statt
verdammen nicht jeder Impfgegner ist
verschwörungsideologe Querdenker nicht
pauschal rechtsradikal jeder
verschwörungsgläubige hat seine
Geschichte was sie verbindet verbindet
uns alle
wir alle wollen die Welt um uns herum
verstehen wir alle sehen uns nach dem
Gefühl von Sicherheit und Kontrollen das
heißt wir wollen verstehen gibt es einen
Plan hinter allem ja also was passiert
in der Zukunft und wir alle sehen uns
danach uns besonders zu fühlen mehr als
ein kleines Rädchen im Getriebe zu sein
und verschwörungserzählungen bieten
Menschen genau das sie werden uns wohl
erhalten bleiben als Erbe der Pandemie
Geschichten wie die von Bill Gates
chip-impfungen zerstören derzeit
Familien und Freundschaften die neu
gegründete Berliner Beratungsstelle
Veritas wird gerade zur überrannt von
Anfragen Tobias Meilicke berät
Angehörige von verschwörungsgläubigen
die ihre Liebsten nicht wiedererkennen
sehr spannend auf einmal werden Thesen
vertreten treten die auch antisemitisch
sind das führt zu Verzweiflung und zu
der Frage wen habe ich da eigentlich
geheiratet zum anderen sehen wir einfach
dass dieses Thema
verschwörungserzählungen den Alltag
dieser Menschen wirklich komplett prägt
das fängt damit an dass einer von beiden
vielleicht Zeitungen liest und dann die
Frage nach der Lügenpresse hochkommt das
geht aber weiter wenn es darum geht dass
Kinder in die Schule gehen und die Frage
von Masken und Tests erörtert wird
gerade in Krisenzeiten sind
verschwörungserzählungen reizvoll weil
sie geschickt psychologische
Grundbedürfnisse bedienen sagt Katharina
Nocon Co-Autorin von True facts wer zu
einer kleinen Gruppe mit vermeintlichem
Geheimwissen gehört ist besonders und
fühlt sich nicht mehr ausgeliefert doch
diese Entlastung wird meist zur
belastenden Angstspirale überall lauern
Zeichen der scheinbaren Konspiration sie
treiben verschwörungsgläubige immer
tiefer hinein in den Kaninchenbau eines
hermetisch geschlossenen Weltbildes bei
so gut wie jeder verschwörungserzähl
sind ja so Geschichten über eine
angebliche Verschwörung in Medien oder
Wissenschaft fester Bestandteil die sind
fest damit verboten weil das auch so
eine Art immunisierungsstrategie ist
klar super bequem vor allem für
autoritäre Politiker wenn sie behaupten
können jeder der mich kritisiert der ist
eben Teil der Verschwörung der ist
sozusagen feindlich Strukturen zur
Abkapselung die man aus Sekten und
terroristischen Gruppen kennt auch
verschwörungserzählungen sind nichts
Neues einige halten sich hartnäckig die
vielleicht krasseste
Verschwörungstheorie des 19 Jahrhunderts
ist diese Fiktion von der jüdischen
Weltverschwörung die Protokolle der
weißen von Zion dabei geht es eigentlich
um die Vorstellung dass es eine globale
Elite von strippenzieren gibt die
versuchen überall in der Welt in die
Geschichte einzugreifen im in den
protokollenerweisen von Zion die eine
Fälschung sind sind das eben die Juden
und die Freimaurer
eine Vorstellung auf der das Dritte
Reich gründete heute wird sie sowohl von
Regierungen wie in Ungarn als auch von
der amerikanischen digitalsekte q-annen
verbreitet
verschwörungsmythen gibt es seit es
Regierungen und Religionen gibt das
Internet eröffnete Anfang des
Jahrtausends ein neues Kapitel
nein eleven war der Moment wo sich
einzelne Bürger eben nicht mehr nur aus
dem Fernsehen und aus den Zeitungen
informiert haben über dieses Jahr für
die ganze Welt ziemlich traumatische
Ereignis das auch rätselhaft war sondern
man hat angefangen im Internet zu
recherchieren und in dem Moment beginnt
man so ein bisschen das Gefühl zu haben
jeder kann sich seine eigene Meinung
machen jeder kann sich seine eigene
Geschichte erzählen ob geheimer
cia-angriff bei 9/11 oder die sogenannte
corona-lüge mit verschwörungsgläubigen
über Fakten zu sprechen führe nur zu
Streit und Frust so Meinecke weil der
Angriff aufs Weltbild als Angriff aufs
Selbstbild verstanden wird
wozu wir raten ist empathisch zu sein
das heißt auf sich die Frage zu stellen
was steckt eigentlich hinter dieser
verschwörungserzählung warum braucht
diese Person diese
verschwörungserzählung gerade welches
Motiv steckt dahinter und auch über
Gefühle ins Gespräch zu kommen das heißt
Gefühle die dahinter stehen wie Angst
Ohnmacht aber auch Liebe und Zuneigung
weil eine Person die mir zum Beispiel
verschwörungserzählung erzählt die will
erstmal dass ich was weiß dass ich mich
vielleicht auch schützen kann vor dieser
Verschwörung eine gute Frage die man
Anhängern von verschwörungserzählungen
stellen kann im Gespräch ist was würde
dich eigentlich vom Gegenteil überzeugen
denn Anhänger von
verschwörungserzählungen haben oft von
sich selbst das Bild dass sie besonders
offen besonders unvoreingenommen sind
sie sehen sich als kritische Denker und
folgen kritiklos teils leicht
widerlegbaren Mythen Tatsachen
zersplittern in Meinungen lösen sich so
auf
wenn ich an den Klimawandel einfach
nicht glaube oder denke Impfung ist
fatal dann kann ich nicht mehr sinnvoll
über Impfung diskutieren insofern ist
dieses alles problematisieren die
Wirklichkeit völlig neu definieren zum
Teil auch eine Aufkündigung der
Streitkultur
die Erosion von Wirklichkeit sprengt den
Grundkonsens darüber was real ist seit
Jahren gibt es zwischen 10 und 30
Prozent verschwörungsgläubige in
Deutschland aktuell Glauben ca 12
Millionen an eine corona-verschwörung
wir müssen uns ernsthaft damit
auseinandersetzen wie erreichen wir
diese Menschen wieder wie bringen wir
ihn unser demokratisches System wieder
näher bzw wie lenken wir eigentlich das
politische Engagement was sie haben in
unserer demokratischen Strukturen zurück
denn man muss eine Sprache sprechen auch
um uneins zu sein zweifeln streiten und
selbst entscheiden das ist Demokratie
wer sich daran erinnert braucht keine
verschwörungserzählung